spitzenkandidaten aber eigentlich steht
einer im mittelpunkt und das ist der
fraktionschef der jetzt das wort bekommt
gregor gysi
herr präsident meine damen und herren
also ich finde ja diese debatte schön
aber wir sollten das zur ständigen
einrichtung machen immer etwa drei
wochen vor der bundestagswahl machen wir
eine richtige wahlkampf debatte und wenn
man das so nennen da muss man sich auch
nicht davor drücken wahlkampfreden zu
halten
ich habe ihnen zugehört und habe
festgestellt dass die kanzlerin unter
brüderle mit sich selbst sehr zufrieden
sind
ob das ausreicht ist allerdings eine
andere frage und bei ihnen herr
steinbrück habe ich festgestellt dass
ihr eine umverteilung der argumente
organisieren von den linken zur spd sehr
spät ehrlich gesagt aber immerhin zum
teil zumindest aber brüder die sie haben
etwas sehr bemerkenswert dass gesagt sie
haben gesagt ja wir sind auch sie haben
gesagt seit vier jahren müssen sie den
mist aufräumen der bis dahin entstanden
war dann sagen sie natürlich der
kanzlerin die es ja schon seit acht
jahren kannst drin dass sie vier jahre
lang mitgemacht ich will es mal sagen
das müssen dann miteinander klären
müssten miteinander
während kommen aber zum ernst der
angelegenheit
wir hatten ein höchst wahrscheinlich
zumindest einen giftgasanschlag in
syrien mit über 1400 toten das kann man
gar nicht scharf genug verurteilen und
das völkerrecht sieht dafür auch etwas
vor das nämlich ganz exakt die
verantwortlichen zu ermitteln sind und
die sind dem internationalen
strafgerichtshof in den haag zu
übergeben und das wird auch eines tages
passieren aber das völkerrecht sieht 1
nicht vor dass die antwort krieg sein
sollen das steht nirgendwo
und ich sage ihnen ich finde die usa
auch nicht besonders glaubwürdig wir
hatten nämlich schon mal einen giftgas
anschlag im irak durch hossein das sind
über 5.000 kurdinnen und kurden ermordet
worden und damals hat den usa mit der
androhung des vetorechts eine scharfe
resolution des sicherheitsrates
verhindert und danach kam nur so ein
appell dass künftig zu lassen was nicht
besonders viel wert war
und wenn man jetzt einen krieg schlag
gegen syrien durchführt kann doch die
situation völlig unbeherrschbar werden
wer weiß dann was dann assad macht der
kann den konflikt noch tragen in den
libanon und noch nach jordanien
wer weiß was der iran mag wer weiß was
die türkei machte ihr unbedingt so
schnell wie möglich ein marschieren will
in syrien wer weiß was russland macht
wer weiß was israel macht die usa
erzählen sie machen da was von 24 oder
48 stunden
in wirklichkeit kann da ein feld brand
entstehen der völlig unbeherrschbar ist
und da bin ich blöd muss das sagt da bin
ich wo einer partei anzuhören die von
anfang an klar nein gesagt hat während
sie an rom gefeiert haben und auch sie
herr steinbrück erst unsere argumente
übernommen haben nach der sitzung des
britischen unterhauses das heißt sie
haben taktisch reagiert und nicht aus
überzeugung und das nervt mich
natürlich brauchen wir eine
verständigung zwischen russland und den
usa und die erste verständigung müsste
mal lauten keine waffen mehr zu liefern
an syrien während keine waffen verkauft
worden an syrien weder in die eine noch
die andere seite wäre der krieg längst
beendet und außerdem brauchen wir dann
natürlich auch eine friedenskonferenz
und warum werden so viele waffen
verkauft weil so viel daran verdient
wird auch das müssen wir ändern
sie wissen ja auch wie groß die
waffenexporte aus deutschland sind und
ich sage ihnen dass es wirklich höchste
zeit wird dass wir ganz anders
herangehen mittels kriegen werden wir
die probleme der menschheit niemals
lösen und deshalb bin ich froh dass es
eine partei gibt die sich immer dagegen
stellt aber es geht noch etwas was sie
bisschen vergessenheit
wir haben patriot raketen und soldaten
in der türkei an der grenze zu syrien
jetzt stellen sie sich doch mal vor die
türkei greift jetzt militärisch syrien
an
dann darfst du hinsicht militärisch wäre
dann müssten unsere soldaten doch
höchstwahrscheinlich die raketen
losschicken ich bitte sie dann helfen
wir nicht einem angegriffenen sondern
einem angreifer einen aggressor
aber das ist nur das eine das zweite ist
deutschland wird dann kriegspartei im
nahen osten nicht bitte sie das ist das
letzte was sich deutschland historisch
moralisch und politisch leisten kann
deshalb müssen die soldaten und raketen
und bezüglich abgezogen
und weil wir noch nicht genau wissen was
passiert am 19 september tag der
amerikanischen presse ich sage ihnen wir
werden danach hier eine sondersitzung
machen müssen um zu entscheiden wollen
sie wirklich dass deutschland
kriegspartei im nahen osten wird oder
nicht dazu müssen sie sich dann hier
bekennen
deshalb werden wir das beantragen und
ich hoffe sogar auf die zustimmung der
anderen fraktionsvorsitzende
es gibt natürlich noch andere gründungen
zu wählen es gibt ja an diesem bundestag
wie ich immer sage eine konsenssoße
zwischen fdp union grünen und spd
es sind sechs gebiete wo sie sich einig
sind wohl nur wir widersprechen
und jetzt sage ich ihnen etwas ja die
linke ist ein ungeheurer demokratischer
gewinn für den bundestag noch kein
einziger kriegseinsatz der bundeswehr
ist gegen eine ihrer fraktion
entschieden worden immer haben alle vier
fraktionen zugestimmt nur die linke hat
immer konsequent dagegen gestimmt und
das war in übereinstimmung mit der
mehrheit der bevölkerung die
waffenexporte haben alle regierungen
genehmigt kohl schröder merkel ihre vier
fraktionen stehen für die erlaubnis von
waffenexporten
wir stellen uns dagegen und wir meinen
wir müssen nicht der drittgrößte
waffenexporteur der welt sein nach 45
hätten wir auch sagen können wir wollen
nie wieder an kriegen verdient und wer
waffen verkauft muss wissen jede waffe
findet ihren krieg
die völlig falschen wege zur überwindung
der euro-krise sind sie immer zu viert
gegangen union fdp spd und grüne alle
sogenannten rettungsschirme haben sie
immer gemeinsam beschlossen und dann
sagt doch herr steinbrück in dem duell
mit ihnen frau bundeskanzlerin auf die
frage einer journalistin warum er alles
kritisiert was in griechenland spanien
und portugal passiert warum man denn
dann immer zugestimmt hat sagt er das
sei ausdruck der europa
verantwortlichkeit der spd ich finde das
eine frechheit das muss ich ihnen sagen
was ist denn was ist denn daran europa
verantwortlich wenn man den süden
europas ruiniert was ist denn daran
europa verantwortlich wenn man dafür
sorgt dass der süden die darlehen
zurückzahlen kann und zustimmt dass die
deutschen für 27 prozent all dieser
darlehen haften wenn ich die
bundesregierung frage wo können sie das
bezahlen wollen wenn es denn fertig wird
denn sagen die mir es wird schon nicht
so kommen das ist alles das hat aber mit
perspektivischer politik gar nichts zu
tun
und um was ganz klar bei griechenland zu
beweisen
infolge der auflagen gerade auch von der
deutschen regierung sind die schulden
von 120 prozent auf 100 75 prozent
gestiegen die arbeitslosigkeit die die
jugendarbeitslosigkeit liegt jetzt bei
64 prozent
insgesamt ist die arbeitslosigkeit um
193 prozent gestiegen und die wirtschaft
geht um 24 prozent zurück und die
steuern auch wovon sollen die denn was
zurückbezahlen deshalb sage ich ihnen
herr schäuble mit einem neuen mit neuen
krediten wird das auch nichts merken was
sie da ankündigen dass erhöht ja die
verschuldung deshalb wird es einen
schuldenschnitt geben ganz egal wie wir
dazu stehen und das kostet dann richtig
unser geld und ich finde das müssten sie
den leuten ehrlich vor der wahl sagen
was sie aber nicht machen
übrigens ist das nicht nur sozial grob
ungerecht die kaufkraft sinkt unsere
exporte gehen zurück also wir schneiden
uns auch noch ins eigene fleisch
aber all dem haben immer alle vier
fraktionen zugestimmt und weder die
grünen noch die spd können sagen wir
haben ja nicht gewusst dass das dabei
herauskommt sie haben es ganz genau
gewusst und trotzdem mit ja stimmen
was brauchen wir wirklich wir brauchen
eine finanzmarktregulierung wir brauchen
eine verkleinerung der banken und
sollten sie organisieren wie sparkassen
und ich bin es auch leid dass jede bank
gerettet wird die können sich
verspekulieren so viel sie wollen die
aktienbesitz wir haben ja nichts zu
flüchten
die steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler
übernehmen das ja kein mensch hilft ein
bäckermeister der vor der insolvenz
steht aber immer bei den banken wird
alles bezahlt ich will auch die rettung
der guthaben der bürgerinnen und bürger
und der unternehmen
aber ich will nicht die aktienbesitzer
red nur nicht die anteilseigener retten
das muss endlich aufhören auch eine bank
pleitezugehen wenn sie denn pleite ist
und wir wollen natürlich
steuergerechtigkeit darüber regt sich
herr brüderle immer so aber jetzt sage
ich ihnen ein zu unserer
steuergerechtigkeit gehören auch
entlassungen entlastung die sich gar
nicht trauen sie wollen die berühmte
kalte progression zu überweisen das ja
also übersetzen das ja nicht abschaffen
das ist ja nicht falsch aber es reicht
gar nicht wir müssen dem
mittelstandsbauch beseitigen die mitte
der gesellschaft zahlt hier alles der
finanziell untere teil kann es nicht und
an den oberen trauen sie sich eigentlich
rein und sie wollen auch nicht an ihn
heran und deshalb muss die lehrerin und
der polizist und die facharbeiterin und
der meister und die kleinen
selbstständigen die bezahlen die
bundesrepublik deutschland schwanken sie
noch mal mit uns zusammen den
mittelstandsbauch ab beider steuer dann
gingen denen das viel besser allerdings
allerdings müssen wir das an eine
bedingungen knüpfen nämlich an den
bedingungen den spitzensteuersatz zu
erhöhen weil die einnahmen aus der lohn-
und einkommenssteuer nicht sinken dürfen
davon leben die kommune nur diesen doch
heute schon pleite die können nicht noch
weiter gemacht werden deshalb sage ich
ihnen beide schritte freibetrag erhöhen
auf 9300 euro mittelstandsbauch
beseitigen und den spitzensteuersatz
erhöhen und dann wird die gesellschaft
auch gerecht und dann müssen wir über
diese dinge nicht mehr diskutieren an
bundesinnenminister füllt der leider
nicht mehr das habe ich auch eine frage
der hat ja sein vetorecht eingelegt und
hat gesagt die armen bulgaren und die
armen rumänen dürfen ja nicht
entscheiden wo sie am leben deshalb
dürfen sie nicht reisen nach deutschland
ist seine logik ich meine logik aber
wenn es seine logik ist dann frage ich
sie mal warum gilt das nur für die armen
warum gilt das nicht für die reichen
warum gilt das nicht für die konzerne
warum durch die sich immer aussuchen wo
sie am wenigsten steuern bezahlen wenn
diese logik auf die arten für die arm
gilt dann muss sie endlich auch für die
reichen und für die konzerne gelten denn
ich sag ihnen auf was bei den fans
da sagen sie immer die nutzen alle
steuerschlupflöcher der gesetzgeber
schafft die steuerschlupflöcher
dann lassen sie uns die doch schließen
ich möchte dass die konzerne übrigens
dort steuern bezahlt wo die
wertschöpfung stattfindet wo die
produktion stattfindet und nicht wo sie
fiktiv unten halben präsidenten
hinsetzen mit einem viertel büro und
dann bezahlen sie dort in liechtenstein
oder weiß ich wo die steuer schützt
damit wo das hergestellt wird wo die
dienstleistung erwartet da müssen auch
die steuern bezahlt dafür müssen wir
sorgen in deutschland und natürlich
neben der steuergerechtigkeit die bei
auch in griechenland dringend benötigen
würden müssen wir endlich die
steuerpflicht an die staatsbürgerschaft
bin dann wäre nämlich das problem gelöst
dann können ja die reichen hinziehen wo
sie wollen
sie bleiben aber wenn sie deutsche sind
in deutschland steuerpflichtig und wenn
die griechen sind in griechenland
steuerpflichtig warum setzen sie das
nicht durch das wäre doch ein ganz
wichtiger schritt gilt übrigens in den
usa wirklich herr brüderle beim besten
willen kein sozialistisches land sie
können diese regelung also aufnehmen und
damit könnten wir eben die eine oder
andere katastrophe verhindern
und dann brauchen wir für griechenland
auf baukredit und wenn wir dort den
tourismus wenn wir die solarenergie wenn
wir die schiffsindustrie aufbauten dann
hätten sie auch ein name und wenn sie
einnahmen haben können sie auch alles
zurückzahlen
sie organisieren dass sie gar nicht
zahlungsfähig sind
das damit letztlich die deutschen
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler das
zu 27 prozent zu bezahlen haben dann
geht s viertes ihr viertes letztes
gewalten des gesetzes sondern ein
viertes gemeinsames thema aller vier
fraktionen ist die senkung des
rentenniveaus die teilprivatisierung mit
der riester rente und die rentenkürzung
mit um zwei jahre ab 67 sie bringe
sowieso durcheinander wissen man kann ja
mit 90 noch im bundestag rumblödeln oder
dass es einer merkt aber an dach können
sie nicht decken das ist der unterschied
also sich die stellenanforderungen das
hat mit den realitäten im leben nichts
zu tun
außerdem leben wir doch in einer alters
rassistischen gesellschaft bewerben sie
sich doch mal irgendwo mit über 50 da
haben sie gar keine chance und sie sagen
die leute müssen immer später die rente
bekommt das ist der falsche weg die
produktivität steigt wenn wir
endlich wirkliche reform schritte gehen
alle mit erwerbseinkommen der nächsten
generation einzahlen müssen ohne
beitragsbemessungsgrenze und bei
abflachung des renteneinstiegs für die
bestverdienende wäre alles bezahlbar
selbstverständlich auch eine rente ab 65
jahre und ohne senkung des rentenniveaus
bei einer ankopplung an die
lohnentwicklung
das wäre möglich aber verstehen sie dass
sie das nicht wollen die fdp verstehe
ich ja noch aber warum die spd das nicht
will sondern auch nur den weg der
rentenkürzung geht ist mir völlig
unverständlich und ist doch gut das ist
die linke gibt die dagegen argumentiert
sonst wären die rentnerinnen und rentner
diesbezüglich hier gar nicht vertreten
das wäre vielleicht ein vga zustand und
dann die prekäre beschäftigung
25 prozent der beschäftigten sind prekär
beschäftigt ein erzwungener teilzeit in
minijobs in leiharbeit aufstocken
aufsteiger da haben sie mal gesagt frau
bundeskanzlerin sie sind stolz darauf
dass der staat den zusätzlich war seit
wir subventionieren die löhne mit neun
milliarden euro jährlich und ich sage
ihnen ich finde das einen einzigartigen
skandal wie einen deutschland ein
vollzeitjob hat muss anspruch auf einen
lohn hahn mit dem er in würde leben kann
und nicht noch zum jobcenter geschickt
werden das ist ja völlig abschluss und
leiharbeit
leiharbeit muss verboten werden weil da
eine entsolidarisierung organisiert wird
die verdienen die hälfte bis zwei
drittel
und dann sagt man der stammbelegschaft
ja wenn ihr nicht auf weihnachtsgeld und
urlaubsgeld verzichtet dann werden wir
noch mehr leiharbeit machen
auch diese entsolidarisierung muss
endlich aufhören und deshalb sage ich
ihnen ja wir haben dem grössten den
größten niedriglohnsektor und europa ein
haar kauder der es größer als in
griechenland und in zypern sie sollten
sich dafür schämen
wir haben neun millionen menschen die zu
wenig verdienen trotz
arbeitsverhältnisse und dann haben wir
noch mal 75 millionen menschen in mini
jobs und sie sagen es geht allen gut
reden sie doch mal mit diesen leuten die
vier euro die stunde verdient oder die
ein mini cooper
dem geht es nicht gut ganz im gegenteil
dann haben wir noch den missbrauch der
werkverträge und dann haben wir die
vielen vielen befristeten verträge von
den beschäftigten bis zum alter von 35
jahren haben 52 prozent mehr als die
hälfte befristete verträge seien sie
dann beschwert sich die union immer und
holten wir einmal die backen voll dass
die deutschen aussterben weil jedes jahr
mehr deutsche sterben als geboren werden
ja wie soll man denn
verantwortungsbewusst kinder in die welt
setzen wenn man gerade man vertrag für
ein halbes jahr hat das ist doch abstrus
und dann außerdem haben wir noch 16
verschiedene schulsysteme bei 16
bundesländer haben das gehört auch ins
19 und nicht ins 21 jahrhundert also sie
müssen die bedingungen kein land dann
wird es auch wieder mehr kinder gehen
und das sechste und das sechste ist aber
sie sind sich alle einig es tut mir leid
herr steinbrück sie wollen die kleine
korrektur die grünen wollen eine kleine
korrektur sie wollen nichts korrigieren
bei der prekären beschäftigung die
einzigen die prekäre beschäftigung über
wien über ist die linke es tut mir leid
da sie ihr einzel
und dann komme ich zur hartz 4 alle vier
fraktionen finden habt ihr richtig und
sagen vom grundsatz her muss man das
aufrechterhalten da meine kleine
korrektur da mal eine kleine korrektur
nein das ganze ist demütigend und
verletzend organisiert und wenn es um
das existenzminimum geht darf man das
nicht noch mit sanktionen unterscheiden
das verletzt auch den artikel 1 des
grundgesetzes und deshalb wollen wir
eine sanktionsfreie mindestsicherung und
ist höchste zeit dass wir die
einführenden deutschland das ist ja auch
interessante zahl die durchschnittliche
verweildauer in der früheren
arbeitslosenhilfe
2004 lag bei knapp einem jahr die
durchschnittliche verweildauer bei hartz
iv liegt bei 25 jahren es hat sich mehr
als verdoppelt
das ist die realität also ich sage noch
einmal ohne die linke während diese
themen im bundestag nie so kontrovers
diskutiert wird
die linke ist ich sage es noch einmal
ein gewinn für die demokratie weil wir
in diesen fragen die mehrheit der
bevölkerung vertreten ohne uns hätte
wäre die hier nicht einmal durch ein
argument vertreten dass wir nur eine
minderheit sind weiß ich aber insofern
bereichern wir dieses land und ich finde
dass man uns schon deshalb weil sie ja
immer gesagt haben wie man wählen muss
muss ich jetzt auf das auch mal sagen
die linke wählen muss aber es geht
weiter
komme ich mal zur regierung also ich
habe es schon gesagt von der
chancengleichheit in der bildung sind
wir meilenweit entfernt ihr
betreuungsgeld ist eine solche
fehlkonstruktion wirklich da muss man
gar nicht darüber diskutiert die
norweger haben es eingeführt um wieder
abgeschafft wissen sie arme familien
herr brüderle haben keine wahlfreiheit
die sind so dringend auf das geld
angewiesen dass sie das dann auch
annehmen und damit organisieren sie dass
ihre kinder nicht in kindertagesstätten
gehen und damit fehlt die soziale
bildung und dann haben sie schlechtere
voraussetzungen für die schule was soll
denn dieser wahnsinn lassen sie uns doch
endlich chancengleichheit für kinder
gerade in der bildung herstellt versüßte
sei höchste zeit die strompreise steigen
sie haben nichts dagegen getan
die mieten steigen sie quatschen nur um
sie machen nichts dagegen in der
regierung das geht doch nicht erklären
sie mir doch mal wenn frau auszieht und
frau bvb einzieht und der vermieter
nichts geändert wieso der plötzlich
seine wohnung teurer machen darf wieso
er hat doch die brücken die den wert der
wohnung gar nicht gesteigert was haben
wir ja eigentlich für komische regeln
das kann man ändern wenn man will dass
es erträglich wird für die menschen
natürlich brauchen wir auch mehr
sozialen wohnungsbau es ist doch völlig
klar
dann könnte jedoch eines nicht leugnen
die entwicklung geht doch immer weiter
auseinander
wir hatten mal ein privates
nettovermögen von etwa viereinhalb
millionen im jahre 2012 von zehn
billionen euro
und 0,6 prozent der haushalte gehört
davon ein anteil von 2 millionen das
heißt von 20 prozent und 50 prozent die
finanziell unteren haushalte 50 prozent
besitzen davon 1 prozent 1 prozent und
1998 hatten diese 50 prozent noch vier
prozent die schere geht immer weiter
auseinander
ja und deshalb sage ich ihnen da hat der
brüder lehrer recht wir haben eine
umverteilung von unten nach oben und es
stimmt die hatten wir auch bei schröder
die hatten haben wir auch bei ihnen die
haben wir auch bei merkel die haben wir
bei ihnen allen und deshalb sage ich
ihnen diese umverteilung von unten nach
oben muss gestoppt werden wir brauchen
für mehr gerechtigkeit
nicht eine umverteilung von oben nach
unten ist höchste zeit dass wir das auch
größere übrigens auch bei gesundheit und
pflege haben sie nichts getan werden
immer noch die zwei klassen medizin und
auch das ist unerträglich wir schlagen
hier überall alternativen vor und jetzt
sage ich ihnen noch kann ich ihnen alles
erzählen aber ich habe ja leider größte
eine begrenzte zeit ja zum beispiel wir
brauchen keine privatkassen wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass drei bis vier
gesetzliche krankenkasse das ganze
regulieren die gesundheit organisiert
und zwar nach art der erkrankung nicht
nach der sozialen stellung des patienten
das ist das entscheidende das ist das
entscheidende
aber jetzt sage ich ihnen etwas fast die
union sehr erregen wird aber es stimmt
wir sind inzwischen die einzige partei
der deutschen einheit wir inzwischen
zwischen ich sag nicht von anfang an ich
sage nicht von anfang an
ich sag euch von anfang an werden sie
doch mal zu ich sage inzwischen und ich
will ihnen auch sagen warum weil wir die
einzigen sind die dafür kämpfen dass man
in ost und west endlich für die gleiche
arbeit in gleicher arbeitszeit den
gleichen lohn erhält und für die gleiche
lebensleistung die gleiche rente das
machen sie nicht dass torpedieren sie
seit jahren und damit 210 sie die
gesellschaft
wir waren 2009 bei der wahl so stark
dass die bundeskanzlerin sogar
angekündigt hat die rentenwerte ost west
werden angeglichen
dann haben wir so ein gutes ergebnis
erzielt dass csu cdu und fdp das sogar
ihren koalitionsvertrag aufgenommen
haben aber wir waren noch nicht stark
genug dass sie es auch machen
sie haben es dann wieder gestrichen und
sagen jetzt es wird nie stattfinden und
die grünen sagen renten angleichung der
rentenwerte sofort aber ohne jede
steigerung der ost-renten das ist
natürlich abenteuerlich kann ich nur
sagen ich will gar nicht weiter darauf
eingehen aber ich will sagen wir
brauchen diese wir brauchen endlich die
gleiche rente für die gleiche
lebensleistung und wer das nicht will
der spalte die gesellschaft der sorgt
nicht für ein
also ich komme zum schluss und stelle
noch mal folgendes fest ohne die linke
herrschte in diesem bundestag gähnende
langeweile
das ist schon mal ein grund uns stärker
hier hinein zu werden
das stimmt die fdp hat ihm zugestimmt
will ich nur sagen zweiter
zweitens ohne die linke gebe es keinen
widerspruch einer fraktion gegen kriege
waffenexporte falsche
euro-rettungsschirme gegen die senkung
des rentenniveaus und die rentenkürzung
zunächst um zwei jahre soll ja noch
weiter gehen
gegen prekäre beschäftigung und gegen
hartz 4
das wäre eine verarmung der demokratie
auch deshalb ist es wichtig diesen
widerspruch zu wählen diesen widerspruch
zu hängen dann gibt es noch einen punkt
weil sie in diesen sechs punkten so napp
konsenssoße sind reagieren sie ja nie
aufeinander
die grünen ändern und ihre politik muss
weil die fdp zulegt oder verliert die
fdp ändert sich ihre politik weil die
union zu liegt die spd ändern auch nicht
ihre politik die einzige partei auf die
sie alle reagieren
das ist die linke und dass das macht
unsere wahl wirklich auch so attraktiv
für die leute sehen sie man wählt uns
und noch bevor wir einen dummen antrag
gestellt haben ändern sie schon ihre
politik so schnell geht das das schafft
man nur mit der wahl der linken und
deshalb deshalb sage ich ihnen doch als
es kann ja sagen die immer wenn wir
stärker werden werden die grünen
friedlicher und immer werden wir stärker
werden wird die spd sozialer und selbst
die union kriegt dann kleinen sozialen
tick also ich meine das ist gar nicht
anders ich gebe zu die fdp ist dagegen
gefeit aber die anderen verteilt aber
die anderen drei parteien
sie richten sich schon nach unten
in wahlergebnissen und deshalb sage ich
ihnen dass es auch ein vorteil von uns
und dann weil er so viel über
koalitionen und alles mögliche
gesprochen wird
liebe spd ich weiß ja ihre
leidensfähigkeit ist fast unbegrenzt
aber ich gebe die hoffnung nicht auf
dass es doch irgendwo eine grenze gibt
was wir wollen ist doch ganz einfach die
wahl gabriel
wir wollen noch nicht dass sie links von
der spd stehen da stehen wir doch das
ist doch gar nicht nötig aber wenigstens
sozialdemokratisch könnten sie doch
endlich werden und zur sozialdemokratie
gehören keine kriege und keine
rentenkürzung und nicht hartz iv
das müssen sie endlich verstehen und
dann können wir nicht nur ein
personalwechsel anstreben sondern
endlich einen politikwechsel und eine
deutlich gerechtere gesellschaft
dankeschön gregor gysi der fraktionschef
der linksfraktion hier mit längerer
redezeit als der spitzenkandidat der
opposition peer steinbrück und ganz am
schluss kam das worauf ich schon
gewartet hatte natürlich sein angebot an
die spd in jedem fall an den mann von
dem er sich am meisten verspricht von
gabriel doch mit ihm zusammen zu gehen
und lego gysi hatte hier seine rede
eröffnet mit dem vorschlag man möge das
doch alle vier jahre wiederholen hier so
eine generaldebatte geologie ist auch
schon sehr lange in diesem parlament und
diese generaldebatte gibt es eigentlich
regelmäßig denn eigentlich geht es hier
heute ja um die einbringung des
haushaltes das muss der gesetzgeber
macht